social accountability having other
people around you who are healthy is as
important as quote-unquote biological
luck it's true the people around you
really do shape your expectations and
how you show up in the world and in this
category more than anything else if the
people around you tend to be healthy
whether that is emotionally healthy
mentally healthy physically healthy your
odds go way up especially the odds of
conscientious discipline and design your
ability to surround yourself with people
who are in a good place is one of the
great gifts of our life we are social
animals a lot of what we do in life is a
memetic meaning we kind of copy what we
see of others we set expectations on
ourselves of what we see of others a lot
of our behaviors our habits our mental
models are really a fact of sociology
and when you understand the people you
surround yourself with you talk with you
look at you work out with you're around
you're healthier need motivation watch
the top 10 of believe Nation because I
love it hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos is because in my first
business I quit on my business partner I
was making 300 bucks a month and I
didn't have the motivation to keep going
and the thing that got me through was
studying the stories of entrepreneurs
who've had massive success and I hope
that in sharing these stories with you
you find a motivation to keep going and
if I'm being honest I still need the
source for myself today too so today
let's learn from one of the best Brendan
burchard and my take on his top 10 rules
of success
enjoy
I am a greatly healthier person in my
life because of my wife and for most men
out there or those who are Partners in
couples where one other partner is
healthier than the other that's one of
the greatest Gifts of all time you know
I'm a way healthier person I don't think
I knew what kale was until I met Denise
was kale what'd you talk about like I
hadn't I had no idea no idea broccoli
what what why wait that's bro how come
it's dark like that I mean there are no
cheese on it I had no idea so that was
important for me to learn a lot about
and all of my friends in the health and
wellness category like being around them
all the time and seeing their posts and
their Instagrams or being at conferences
and studying their work or going to
conferences they're about health
surrounding myself in an ecosystem has
made me healthier
I really has if you look at where I grew
up
to where I am now I mean it's totally
different peer set and that was by
Design you might not get to choose your
biology or all your family but you get
to choose your peers and your friends
and The Inspirations who you follow or
learn from especially in this category
of Health once you have that energetic
Vision I promise you'll surround
yourself with better people social
accountability work out with friends get
a trainer they expect you to show up so
you show up Social accountability
surround yourself with people who expect
you to do well who expect you to take
care of yourself who are empathetic when
you're struggling because they
themselves are empathetic people who
struggle too right having vulnerable
honest open
truthful transparent humans around us
who enable us and allow us to be
vulnerable
to share our hurts our pains our shames
our sadness increases our mental health
rule number two develop good routines so
routine or we could call it a habit or
what I like to call in our high
performance research we talk about the
phrase of a deliberate
practice or a deliberate habit I
personally deeply believe that people
who want to be healthy who think their
habits are going to carry them over the
line don't know how work how life
actually works right we've fallen in
love with these simple gimmicky habits
that we're supposed to do and the way of
thinking about habits that's not how it
works when you grow
growth requires deliberate habits not
automated habits it just happen they're
so easy and also no deliberate habits
okay I'm going to do this today I'm
going to implement this thing I'm going
to choose to do that as a routine and as
a practice as a deliberate habit that I
have to like conscientiously decide to
go to even it's hard
routines
you know those might be
eating well
working out well sleeping well
finding out what works for you which
we'll talk about in a moment
but here's the deal if you don't know
your routines if you don't have patterns
practices or plans for your health
how are you supposed to ever feel your
best or even feel better
you gotta have a plan in place
one of my favorite things to do is when
I work with a client and some of you
know when I work with like one-on-one
with the client it's a big deal I rarely
do that anymore you're talking about
like seven figure levels of work very
rare that I'll do that with but one of
my favorite things to do with an actual
paying client is ask them to take a
picture for me
of their list
of health habits
and you know what they usually say
oh gosh Ben I don't have one
I go nowhere written down in your house
is a list
of your health habits or your health
goals it's not written down well no
did you ever Journal about it
well yeah I guess one time you know on
New Year's four years ago
they don't even it's not even written
there's no plan
they'll tell you I'll ask what you're
well you know I I like this routine or
you know I like kale you know they'll
tell you something you know I had to
drop a kale joke up in here it'll be
like they'll have an idea
they'll have a list of things that
they'll pontificate on that works for
them once in a while
it's nowhere written down
you know I love my friends when for the
first time they go to run a marathon and
often they'll get a coach or they'll
start reading books on it or uh you know
they'll look something up on the
internet and realize oh to run a
marathon there's a plan
and listen if you just go in and try to
run a marathon yourself I guess a small
percentage of the planet could figure it
out and actually pull it off the rest of
us humans we follow a plan that plan is
starting small getting a little bit
better focusing on these things running
a little bit longer and a little bit
longer and a little bit better and then
all of a sudden you ran a marathon is an
incremental approach but guess what
there's a plan
no plan no gains
no plan no change
no goals no growth
and so if you want Health to be
something important in your life where's
the list where is the plan even it's
simple
we need the routine we need the plan we
need the goals write it down do it today
put it in your journal in growth day go
make a plan in growth day I'm going to
start doing these things put it in there
set reminders and growth day literally
you can pop up you can write your
reminders and growth day drink water
have it pop up a couple times a day as a
notification you know eat healthy
tonight have it pop up as a reminder you
can set up reminders and growth day if
you didn't know which are a hugely
popular thing for People's Health so go
set up reminders just go to the plan
section of your growth Day app after
this broadcast today and set up your
plan rule number three have self-respect
would you go to
you know one of your random neighbor's
house
would you go there
and you know pull up in a big with a big
dump truck of garbage and shovels and
and just go start shoveling in and
breaking their windows and vandalizing
their house
of course everyone says well no I
wouldn't unless you hate your neighbor
what are you talking about Brandon when
I vandalize my neighbor's house and
throw garbage in of course I wouldn't
and yet we vandalize the very Temple
that we have been given
we throw garbage in the very Temple that
we have been given
and what I found through years of
studying psychology but also actually
doing the academic research and also
doing the field testing with all our
millions of high performance clients
over the years is as one self-respect
and self-worth go up
their health habits improve
in fact often when their health habits
improve their self-respect goes up I
really believe it is a Perpetual
Evergreen Loop someone with greater
self-respect and self-love of course
they want to care for their Temple
because they care for their life
they tell they care for their energetic
Force they see themselves as stewards of
the temple or stewards of the energy or
the spark inside
they care for their energy levels
because they care for themselves
and I've been there so if you think I'm
preaching here for those who don't know
my story and when I was 19 years old I
had suicidal ideation and planning
I'd had a huge breakup in my life I did
not have the emotional tools
needed to deal with that situation in my
life
and so I fell into a deep pattern of
self-hatred
and stop taking care of myself
entirely I mean entirely not eating not
showering not you know doing anything
and so I understand that path I've been
down that path I've coached through that
path and I have to share with you that
we have to be attentive
to the Deep correlation
between how we care about ourselves and
think of ourselves and our self-worth
and our health practices
it's really vital it's very important if
you're not taking care of yourself
there's an emotional reason and an
identity reason something about yourself
that you are blocked by upset about
angry about sometimes disgusted about or
there's that self-hatred and so I'm
telling you here I'm telling you I'm
here to tell you that is one reason
especially in the world of mental health
I'm always like see a therapist if your
health practices have sucked for two
decades
if you're a health practice has sucked
for a decade
don't blame it on your sweet tooth
go see a therapist
get some emotional support to understand
what's the underlying thing happening
here that I'm not taking care of myself
so I begin our health conversation by
recommending therapy if you have not
been practicing health habits well
especially over a period of time there's
sometimes trauma there
are sometimes negative self-talk there
there's sometimes patterns that are hard
to break without a professional
assisting you and so I'm always that
person who's like hey I'm going to tell
you to optimize I'm going to challenge
you I'm also going to say if you really
struggled with this for a long time get
some help babe sometimes you need that
and so please hear that respectfully
from me because I care about your health
rule number four focus and commit to
sustain motivation you have to do two
things you probably already know first
you have to focus now before you turn
off the video or go the next one listen
to this a lot of people have that
initial desire but they don't look at
their goals every single day they don't
revisit every single let's say Sunday
and say how did I do this week how did I
do in my health in my relationships in
my career how do I do with my finances
how did I do with any other goals that I
set up you have to have that daily
discipline to look and focus on what
you're doing and that weekly review you
also have to have the ability to avoid
distractions one of the reasons people
love my book the motivation Manifesto is
this teaches you how to set boundaries
how to say no how to push away
distraction to own your life again but
here's the deal when you're focusing on
something and you're really dialing in
in it also brings your full presence
into something so you perform at higher
levels the second thing you need outside
of focus is sane motivation is everyday
effort it's the reason you have to set
up habits it's the reason you have to
have a daily routine a morning routine
it's the reason you have to make sure
you have a checklist of to Do's each day
I know that sounds so basic but here's
the funny thing a lot of people think
they'll have motivation one day then
they'll put the effort out it's like
motivation first they think then effort
comes the motivation inspires the effort
right it's actually the opposite in the
science of motivation it's with daily
effort that motivation comes I like to
tell people this with momentum comes
more motivation don't wait for the
motivation to go out and take action
actually take action first because just
a little bit of progress a few quick
wins drops dopamine into the brain we
start feeling good and rewarded for our
behavior and suddenly we find ourselves
more motivation so here's the thing set
three goals each day knock off each of
those three goals if you just did that
each and every single day you'd start
feeling more personal power and you
start getting ahead also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five keep your health
in check there is a evolutionary and a
biological reason that you feel the way
that you do right there is it's very
important to understand in both I really
believe mental health and physical
health it is that kind of 50 50 kind of
thing and when we blend it together by
the way but there's no question that
some people
biologically feel more fatigued or more
depressed or more anxious we have to
understand that you and me are not the
same
biologically in how our energy might be
and I hope that that always introduces
empathy and compassion
that there's a big luck card that we get
I have friends literally who are born
without limbs
I have friends who are born with
conditions in which their brain
functions in very unhealthy ways I have
friends who've died so early of cancer
I have friends who um have struggled
with mental health
I have friends who committed suicide
I have friends and family who struggle
constantly with all sorts of biological
health issues that is quote unquote not
their fault and it's important to
realize that
some of you
you feel terrible biologically even
though you're drinking all your water
you're eating all your greens you do
move and you do exercise
and so I'm here to say there is no
preaching we all have to take the cards
we've been dealt and figure out how to
care for ourselves
how to optimize the best that we can how
to improve
even if it's a little bit incremental by
incremental but it starts with a
biological understanding of where we are
at and this is why again as a person
who's not a medical professional I'm
like listen if you don't understand
closely how you feel and why you feel
the way that you do
please please please if you've never
done it go get a full workup of every
friggin Health test you can as an adult
as somebody who's accountable for your
health go get the blood test go see the
nutritionists or the dietitians go work
out with the trainer go literally do all
the genetic testing that you can do to
understand what's up with you
I always tell the story of A friend of
mine who's one of my partners in one of
my businesses one of my best friends in
the world who discovered at the age of
40.
that you know every morning he always
had the sniffles and his nose was
running and he's clearing his throat and
everything and found at the age of 40
that he was allergic to eggs
at the age of 40. didn't know spent 40
years having these reactions that made
him fatigued and blowing his nose and
everything because he was allergic to
eggs
and I think that's a sad thing about our
society is that we're not
taught or trained or honestly empowered
or equipped or served
with some simple Health
um support When We're Young that says
hey look seems like you're allergic to
this thing don't eat it I mean how is
that not part of our educational process
right or or or or or or or or or our
Health Care system that of course we
would all find out very early on and be
tested multiple stages of our life
including every new decade
what are we allergic to
what preconditions might we have
what's our genetic what's our genetic
makeup leading us towards so this is
where I say health is luck
right Health might be luck but it's your
job to be aware
your job no one else says no one's going
to come and save you here you've got to
do the testing and see the medical
professionals professionals and
dietitians and people who can help you
optimize and care for your body I
believe that has to be something we
demand of ourselves it's not served to
us at least not in society I live in so
we have to take accountability for that
so health is luck dot dot dot rule
number six challenge yourself just
challenge yourself
just challenge yourself
challenge yourself at the gym next time
challenge yourself when you're on the
road next time to go a little bit
further
challenge yourself to get a little
faster challenge yourself to be a little
more mobile or flexible challenge
yourself to stay a little longer in that
yoga pose challenge yourself to reset
your mindset after you get angry or hurt
or down if you're not challenging
yourself who is I know people say but
Brendan isn't perfectionism such a
problematic thing in mental health I'm
like totally totally it is the super
thin slice the reality is perfectionism
isn't the problem the problem is people
think they should be perfect but
perfecting ourselves growing into our
full potential expecting a lot of
ourselves that can be done in healthy
ways especially when you consider all
the things we've talked about today
it's okay to challenge yourself again
last time you might have challenged
yourself maybe you got down on yourself
this time as you challenge yourself
allow the grace do it with social
accountability have an energetic Vision
recalibrate find what feels good for you
and stick to that
you can figure out a way to feel better
you can figure out a way to get
healthier it's going to be on your own
path in your own way no one can tell you
all the right ways to do that you'll
probably need support you'll probably
take months and months and months and
years and years and years to figure it
out and often you'll fall off the wagon
you'll do a terrible thing you'll make a
bad choice but you'll recalibrate and
you'll keep getting better because you
and I both know that every day is a
great day to grow I want to thank you
all for this incredible session today on
health I hope you enjoyed I hope you'll
share with family and friends if it
supported you just go tell people what
we're doing here at growth day like holy
they're having an entire month of
conversations about health about mental
health emotional health physical health
right here in growth day we'll be live
every single week with you guys as
always on our Wednesday wisdoms so tune
back in watch the replays make a
commitment Journal today about your
energy Vision please do that please stay
please stay on path please take care of
yourself please be kind to yourself
please practice self-respect and
self-love you deserve a vibrant and
energetic life do your work to move
towards that to align with that to honor
that impulse and know that you don't
have to do it alone we're all doing it
together we're all figuring out together
we're all on this journey together
that's why we always say every day is a
great day to grow together rule number
seven recalibrate when you fall you're
gonna fall off the wagon you're gonna
have a suck day you're going to be
unmotivated you're going to eat that
pizza you're going to do something that
you know you shouldn't do
because your current mood or the choice
of passion or Joy or spontaneity or the
thing that you like is there
and the most important thing in health
isn't just knowing what to do or having
that plan it's recalibrating when you
fall off
you know in the mental health space and
the personal coaching space we both use
the same term for this it's called
resilience
it's okay
challenge problem something didn't go
the way I'd planned
can I find my strength again find my
focus again and keep progressing
today we're just going to call that
Health recalibrations recalibrations
okay so what you didn't work out
yesterday and you planned two do it
today
okay you ate the terrible food make the
better choice for the next four meals
it's what people do is instead they made
a bad choice they did something bad
self-hatred increased
and so they stop
they stop trying
you know you're down on yourself when
you stop trying you know you're down on
yourself when you don't recalibrate
after a fail
you know you're down on yourself when
something doesn't go right you fail you
feel bad about yourself and you stop
the idea that we talk about here in
growth day all the time it's just making
self-improvement a way of life tomorrow
improve get better try again okay you
you had a huge Outburst guess what I
have a huge Outburst do I keep
outbursting for hours and hours and
hours no huge outbursts whoa that was
off let me go recalibrate over here let
me go on a walk let me bounce in place
take 10 deep breaths let me lay on the
floor do a release meditation let me
stand back up write out my intentions
and go
I don't get down on myself or angry
about myself what I do is go well that's
not what I wanted that wasn't my
intention that wasn't good okay
recalibrate
so I reset my body I reset my mind I
reset my intentions and I go you got it
that's recalibrating
you don't stop and beat yourself up you
go okay let me recalibrate reset
right that is so important the reset or
what I'm calling a recalibration is
everything
and here's what happens
the longer between incident and
recalibration
the worse your health
right people say well
I missed three weeks of working out
screw it guess it doesn't matter
no recalibration so now those three
weeks turn into Six turn into nine turn
to years
but if instead of getting down to
yourself or stopping you said
okay I missed it for three weeks in a
row let me reset what do I really want
here how can I do better let me try
again it's just keep going I know that's
so simplistic but we have to keep
progressing
if we stop
not only do we stop the forward momentum
we increase
I should say we decrease our self-esteem
our self-respect goes down
because we know we should be doing
something for ourselves but we don't
and so this is really important to
understand and hear recalibrate recalib
and make it fast like resiliency doesn't
take five years you know what
recalibrations can happen in moments you
maybe had a bad morning but you're here
you're working on yourself you're here
on growth Day saying you know what I
just sometimes the the the instruction
the positivity the perspective even or
just the reminders it's helpful
every time I listen to a growth day
teacher I feel better not because
everything changed in an instant because
it just it resets me to right okay good
mindset good habits I can do that here I
go
so it's just a recalibration it's a
recalibration I can't tell you how many
bad days I have or bad hours I should
say emotionally that I have that I
choose by the end of the day to
recalibrate okay I had a terrible
morning
whoo let me go for a walk
let me get a bunch of water let me get
some food in my stomach so I'm not
hangry let me come back do a 10 minute
release meditation some seven or eight
Vinyasa flows on the floor get back up
look at my goals on the wall write out
my intentions make my action plan and
get two things done
end of day I feel better
if you follow I'm not perfect
and neither are you
but we are perfecting ourselves
we are in motion of progress when we
recalibrate more quickly so have it in
mind okay bad morning recalibrate bad
hour recalibrate bad conflict
recalibrate for Miss the workout
recalibrate eat the bad thing
recalibrate I hope that serves you rule
number eight improve your
self-perception have you ever had the
pain point where you perceive yourself
different than everybody else around you
you know you think you're this great
amazing person and other people around
you are being mean or maybe sometimes
you're like down on yourself but
everyone's like no you're awesome I love
you what's wrong I love you if you ever
had that it's like there's this
challenge sometimes between our
self-perception and how other people
perceive us so the first thing you have
to do is make sure every single day that
you have a very clear intention for who
you want to be I know you've been
watching my YouTube hopefully for a long
time and you hear me talk about this it
you can't keep bumbling into each day
and just reacting all day you have to
have an intention for like what kind of
person do I want to show up to the world
as like how do I want to be perceived
and be really clear about that don't
just like wander into social situations
all throughout High School all
throughout College all throughout your
professional life showing up as you do
normally instead go how do I really want
to be in this situation how do I want to
feel in this situation how do I want to
treat people in this situation how do I
want other people to perceive me not in
a some kind of method of Conformity but
rather like what's the real mean
if you can't articulate the real you
please don't ask other people to figure
it out if you're not clear about your
own values how you want the world to see
you and what you want to accomplish
please don't ask the world to know who
you are and what you're about
so it begins with that intention that
Clarity of self first you got to do the
homework you got to do the personal
development you got to read the books
you got to geek out and figure out your
values your drives how you want to show
up to people what your goals are because
if you don't know it I promise you we're
never going to figure it out and I think
a lot of people are really miserable in
their life because they're like no one
understands me but they don't understand
themselves or they don't understand
themselves and communicate who they are
so it all begins with intention all
begins with Clarity you gotta start by
defining yourself and every day look at
it I mean like literally every day like
what are the words that should Define
how you're going to be today I have
people write that down every single day
like I want to be a person who is and
write it out I want to treat other
people like this because if every day
you show up as that person and you treat
people like this then Integrity starts
happening in your life you have that
congruence of being who you really want
to be and more people see you on a
consistent basis being like you versus
scatter shock just really acting or
conforming or trying to fit in now when
you know you and you show up as you more
often they go I get you so the second
big thing you can do is learn by
discussion
this is the hardest thing to do and what
this means is ask other people how they
perceive you I mean it's the hardest
thing but let's say you got a job and
you have a great meeting and you feel
good about the meeting lots of people
walk out and just go celebrate and
they'll go I guess I did a great job
instead ask other people like how did
that meeting go for you how do you think
I did was there anything else I could do
better how do you think of the way I
talk to this person is there anything
that you feel like I missed
and just start asking other people to
share the perceptions of you and your
performance it is the gutsiest scariest
thing in the world for people to do
because most people don't want feedback
but if you never solicit feedback if
you're not consistent and asking for it
then people just don't say it and then
one day they're like well I think you're
like this and you're like how could you
say that we've been in a relationship
for 10 years and they're like I guess
you never asked
so you gotta ask ask consistently and
constantly and almost everything you do
be like how is that did I come across as
this I was trying to go for that it did
it work I mean even as we're shooting
this video you know today I shot a
couple of these and I asked my team like
do you think that was like too slow was
it too fast did I get my points across
because if you don't ask that you don't
know and a lot of the external feedback
that comes from others can give you the
real direction for how to be better I
know it's scary I know it's like well
people might say negative things but if
you realize all you're trying to do is
learn not judge everything goes fine if
all you're trying to do is say hey just
give me the honest feedback and don't
worry about saying it exactly right I
won't get hooked I won't get mad you
gotta actually have those conversations
with people allow them to share the
feedback and don't take it personally
take it as a learning point that either
applies and is true for you or not like
I get a lot of feedback I'm like I don't
agree with that that's not true I I
don't think that's true for me I'll try
to do better next time to make sure that
that doesn't happen but I don't ever
hold it against other people now is it
true that some people are going to be
mean to you is it true some people are
going to call you names is it true some
people are going to be hard on you yeah
that's that's part of life so don't be
surprised by it anymore you're too old
now to be surprised by other people
being a jerk to you you should know that
it's going to happen you should know
people are going to give you negative
feedback and what you have to do is
start learning to take feedback from
people who know how to deliver it if
someone gives terrible feedback and
they're a terrible jerk and they're
always that way man don't take that
personally just know that's their style
that's their thing that's their life
that's their you know acts to grind not
yours rule number nine learn to say no
we're always trying to improve our lives
but life is hard things mess you up
people judge you finances are hard and
you're always trying to be your best but
sometimes that ain't easy and so I think
develo developing habits of Mind Body
Spirit productivity service love
can really change your life and I'll
start this morning with a super funny
story uh about just a life-changing
habit of mine you can see I'm in a new
space uh this morning I'm literally in a
shared office right now
and
if I I'll give you a play-by-play of
like the last
41 minutes
41 minutes ago
the power in my studio went out
I'm typing an email to I think about 41
minutes yeah about yeah 41 minutes if
I'm doing the right math right uh and I
figure out about that time that oh wait
no the it's the power to the whole house
and my studio my studio is in like Our
Guest House
and you know I've got the broadcast
camera you guys have all seen over the
years and you know it looks nice setup
and everything
I'm typing an email to all the create
accounts in
um growth day about another promotion
and and also everything goes out
now I know I got this live with you guys
at the top of the hour and I was like
okay
didn't expect that
take a few deep breaths out
swear five times stand up and I go
outside looking for what's happening and
like is there someone out there they've
turned off the power what's going on
across the street what's because there's
construction and I'm looking around
what's happening can't figure it out go
into the house and like I said that
whole house
power seems out
go to uh ask Denise my wife
hey do you know anything is someone
doing anything with a house there's no
power I'm live in like an hour
she's like no I I I don't know and she'd
just been getting out of the shower
she's like I don't know so I go blazing
outside
uh go look across the street there's
construction going on I pick up the
phone call the project manager over
there and I go did you guys just shut
off the power is something going on and
we're doing this Landscaping project so
I bolt over there asked you guys did you
guys are you digging are you digging
anything have you hit power no
and run back into the house
uh and Denise is like hey I just got a
notice from PG e
powers out but doesn't say anything
about it just says notice we you know
it's kind of those Texas says hey your
power might be out we're like yeah we
figured it out
so I go okay
uh I think okay well
um what am I gonna do
I'm live at the top of the hour so I
said okay well and probably come back on
you know probably yeah who's had that
Zoom moment where your power went out
you just thought it'll come back on
anyone else you're just like just Faith
you're thinking about it okay power's
gonna come back on
I said okay but what if it doesn't
so I start packing up a spare laptop
because my other laptop is connected to
all the gear right just in case it comes
on I've got that fancy camera and
everything
oh hold out and I run back inside I said
Okay
um
I'm gonna drive into town and get that
shared office space that we know about
hit up my assistant say can can you book
a space for me I'm gonna I'm gonna be
going in
and then the project manager from across
the street says hey it's not us God
knows from PG e and he sends me this
audio it says there will be no power
till one o'clock
which I'm on Pacific time so that's two
and a half that's three hours away but I
gotta be live with you at the top of the
hour
so okay I listen to the thing the audio
says no no power till one o'clock
the next text comes in from the project
manager hey
I'm coming I'm trying to come over uh to
see if it's anything about your property
because he also worked on our property I
can't get in the gate
we have a gate at the beginning of a
product that's powered
and so all of a sudden I realized
I can't get in my car and drive down to
the shared space because I can't get my
car out of our property the gate don't
open
I'm like oh my God
and this is where that first habit comes
in
I take a deep breath anytime there's a
huge Interruption and Rule Number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is turn defeat into Victory how do
you turn the feeling of defeat into a
success mindset those days you get
disappointed you get sad you get upset
someone makes fun of you and all of a
sudden all of your motivation and your
focus and your drive drains out with the
disappointment how do you turn it around
you know if you went for that big
project and you failed it didn't work
out you put the video out nobody watched
it you know you did what you've been
trying to do but you just didn't get the
accolades or the rewards and now you
feel defeated and like tomorrow you're
kind of like screw it why even try we've
got to learn how to change that mindset
around so we can have some more
resiliency and motivation so that we can
keep at it in our dreams but the
question is how that's what this episode
is about the first thing you have to
remember as soon as defeat strikes and
it will if you're chasing big missions
big purposes things that really matter
to you you're going to have down days
you're gonna have bad days
allow that
everybody wants to be so pollyannaish or
super positive and say oh there is no
defeat there is no failure oh no there's
failure I mean there really is and we
shouldn't stop we should stop pretending
that people don't fall on their face and
and feel bad and have bad days allow it
when you have a bad day allow that
moment to say you know what yeah this
isn't the way I wanted it to go and then
immediately shift into learning
disappointment immediately goes away so
you shift into learning so your question
is first allow it say okay I am
disappointed I have higher standards I
wanted it to go better but instead of
now keep focusing on those things where
you beat yourself up and beat yourself
and beat yourself up you say to yourself
okay what's three things I learned go
and start focusing on what you learned
specifically when you get defeated in
your life I want you to start analyzing
what defeated you but instead of saying
I did bad here and bad here and bad here
turn it into a question about first what
did I learn about myself
second what did I learn about other
people third what did I learn about the
world fourth what can I do about it
that's how you deal with the
disappointments what did I learn about
myself what did I learn about other
people what did I learn about the world
and what can I do now that Focus to
those four questions from any
disappointment or defeat will help
charge you up because you'll be focused
more on the lessons and what you can do
next the second big idea we have a
defeat is this immediately that day that
you got defeated I want you to take
three action steps no matter what those
are sometimes the three action steps are
okay that didn't work out well send an
email to my team explaining or
apologizing sometimes the action step is
to call somebody send a note to somebody
send a text sometimes the action step
can simply be
stop at the grocery store get my
favorite meal so tonight I feel better
about myself whatever it is just make
sure as soon as the disappointment
happens you set three goals that very
day
and do them one of those goals can be
meditate and think about it another goal
can be take a long walk another goal can
be let's exercise another goal can be
call a friend go out to Coffee I don't
care what it is my friend
but you need those goals and you need to
do them immediate because here's the
thing the more momentum you have
it doesn't matter what toward what goal
the more momentum you have the more
motivation you'll feel and that
motivation can often wipe out that
feeling of disappointment and move you
forward and then the third big idea when
you get defeated stop focusing so much
on yourself I know it's easy to to Stew
in your own hurt or your soul your anger
your disappointment but instead start
thinking about that very next day how
can I Rise to another level of service
that's the question I want you to ask
the next day when you wake up that next
day after disappointment say you know
what today I have the opportunity to
serve let me do it with full joy and
heart let me challenge myself this day
yes yesterday wasn't what I want to be
but this day I'm gonna challenge myself
again to serve with full joy and full
heart if you can do these simple things
I know they're just internal dialogues
I'm talking about you're really just
looking at the disappointment or the
defeat and saying okay what did I learn
about myself other people and the world
and what can I do you're really just
saying okay what are three steps I can
take today to get some more momentum
back and you're really just waking up
the next day and saying hey how can I
serve even better today that might sound
so simplistic but most people don't do
those things they keep stewing over and
over and over on the hurt and The Angst
and the stress and so they never break
free if you ask a different quality of
question you can live a different
quality of life and overcome those
appointments so try that next time you
feel down or defeated and you'll start
to experience and live what we call the
charge life
if you are struggling with the sense of
purpose today
you are lacking a routine or a practice
to look at your tomorrows
raise your hand if you got that one
if you are struggling with purpose today
you're simply lacking a routine or
practice to look at your tomorrows
I tell everybody you want to be a better
leader you want to be a better parent
you want your day your health together
you want to build a bigger business you
want to earn more money you got to look
at your tomorrows way more consistently
not on January 1 or December 31st
but daily
that's why I force myself to look at a
year calendar every day
because I'm not good at that and I know
that about myself and sometimes when
you're not good about something you need
to create a habit or routine that you
will stick to and find some joy in so
usually before I get to that wall that
Battle Board I got a cup of green tea in
my hand because I love it
I got a journal next to me because I
love that
I love green tea and I love journaling
I'm not so good at the vision part but
I've created the routine just like on
email I've created a routine there that
helps me go through a process that I
know I need to do but I'm not as good at
y'all follow
so this is what I'm suggesting to you if
you're lacking Vision we need a practice
to look at your future more often
so critical it's why when you do that
morning mindset prompt
in growth day one of the questions asks
what's a project I should keep in mind
that I'll be doing in the future
that I might not be able to do today but
I just need to keep it on the dashboard
of my mind
and people always ask well I when I do
this thing it's kind of the same thing
every day I I gotta you know I wrote
down I'm gonna write a book one day and
I got to write it again and again I'm
like yes you have to again and again and
again think about your future even if
you're not doing anything for today
you know even if you're not taking the
action say you have to think about
you know right now I'm thinking I'm
working on some major media projects I'm
not doing them yet
but I'm thinking about them I take a
moment to think about that project
try to get in the unconscious
kind of scrolling around back then to
connect me to the Future
because when you feel connected to the
Future especially when it's something
that you are choosing to go do to go
build to go manifest
you will feel more purposeful
accountability means you know what my
credit card bills those are mine I'm
accountable for handling those instead
of avoiding them I am personally
responsible to deal with these even if I
didn't cause all these problems
I am now the person who if I'm going to
clear the problems off my plate I gotta
take some personal accountability for
that
I am now the person who gets to choose
my attitude today
I am now the person who expects myself
to follow a higher standard and to
follow through
accountability personal responsibility
or personal accountability says okay
I'm going to own this reality I'm going
to plan my way through it I'm going to
follow through
and I'm going to set up checks and
balances to make sure I do that
where that's setting goals and tracking
and measuring the goals and my own
behavior towards those goals
or getting a coach
sharing socially in the community or
talking with your friends and family and
putting it out there now your butt's on
the line and you got to do it
I think that's what's important
so often we say you know
I have dreams I'm not going to tell
anybody
and often in person development you hear
people say no tell people
because once you verbalized it you can
realize it once you verbalized it and
it's socialized now there's an
expectation you follow through
here's my question too
do you have enough expectations
to follow through
often when I work with CEOs
as as their executive coach what ends up
happening is
they have that kind of
maybe they have investors and their
investors expect them to stay on path
maybe they need to hit their quarterly
goals
um but when something happening is
sometimes they start feeling like their
accountability
is driven by others and often High
performers feel all these obligations
they are accountable but they're
accountable to obligations that other
people have set
and if you want a real fast track to
being demotivated
setting your own plan
stop setting your own accountability
this is why for me as I told you I go in
my plan section of growth every day I
look at those plans I'm like
I'm behind on this
but I don't get discouraged I just make
a plan on how to handle it
sometimes I look at them like I don't
like my score here with my friends I I
went three months without really talking
to my friends I don't get down on myself
I make a plan
I don't fall prey at that victim part of
myself it says but all these other
things are happening and oh my God I
just go okay got it I don't like that
I'm the only one in charge of the ship
you're the only one in charge of those
scores
and once you realize that you're like
okay
I'm accountable what's my plan because
sometimes you've left your
accountability to your boss you left
your accountability to your manager you
left your accountability to your spouse
you left your accountability to the kids
you left your accountability to somebody
else and you didn't internally own it
anymore if you ever been my seminars
before I'll talk about this for a while
and then I'll get the whole audience up
we'll play this music we'll do the
lights and all of a sudden we'll have
everyone start shouting I own my dream I
own my dream I own my dream
to help them realize again
they're the owner of their life
you own your dream you own that impulse
in your heart that says to get better
once you're the CEO of your life
not just a follower
everything shifts for us
and that's accountability you have to
build your network you got to build your
network I like I'm here because I've
told a bajillion people like one day I'd
love to live on a beach and I tell
people in my network and you know maybe
they had a job that was related or not
related maybe they knew people who lived
on a beach maybe they didn't but
everybody around me always knew the
things I wanted to achieve I want to
write a book I want to be a speaker I
want to do podcasting I want to shoot on
YouTube I want to you know be a person
who gets to share about life
transforming ideas and tools that
inspired me
that's what I want to do with my life I
want help people achieve their dreams
faster and improve their lives and I
would tell everybody that even though I
started talking about that when I was
broke
I was struggling I was trying to get my
morning routines and my habits together
and my health together I was trying to
get my mind together it wasn't like I
had everything figured out but I let
people know along the journey what I
wanted and I thought about the people
who would I have to be friends with what
type of people would I have to know in
my industry in order to help me achieve
the abundance to make my dreams come
true so what are the exact types of
people you need to know and I mean what
I want you to think is like who would
you love to have on speed dial on your
phone like the people of your influence
the people in your industry oh you want
to do you want to be a filmmaker great
who are the great directors you would
love to get to meet and have on speed
dial on your phone right you want to
have a job in this career or that
industry who are the industry leaders
and Titans who you would love to have on
speed dial and make it like a game
to get to meet those people add value to
those people befriend those people serve
those people or work for those people so
that now you're in that world because if
you don't know the networks you need to
achieve your dreams your dreams are
really going to be far away so build the
network you need now when we don't have
a vision
for next week next month next year life
can start to feel like we're just in you
know kind of in the swamp
and they were just going through the
motions and oh my God I'm working so
hard Brendan or oh my God Brent I have
all these reasons to be happy I I I
already have the great kids I I have a
house I can afford the car payments I
mean I have all these reasons to be
happy but I don't know something's
missing I don't feel purpose either
it's usually a disconnect or a lack of
clarity
about your future
and I don't mean 10 years out or 50
years out I mean sometimes next month
and next year
really just uh sometimes it's just a
couple month Horizon and lacking Clarity
and connection with just the next couple
months or in some cases if you're a
longer term strategic kind of guy
the next year or two
I can feel that if I feel a disconnect
from my next year or two
I tend to lose a connection with purpose
a connection with motivation
uh I feel like the intentions or the
productivity of the day are kind of like
for what you know it's easy to go I'm
working so hard but for what
and that for what
I know equals vision
what is the vision of your next couple
months or next couple years
no one will give you that
it's time to sit down and think about
that it's why you all know I keep a
battle board over here on the wall and
my Battle Board is like it's basically
like a a
arts and crafts version of a yearly
schedule it's like it's like a big piece
of butcher paper with 12 boxes drawn on
it and the 12 boxes each represents one
month of the year and I create themes
across the boxes I write the major
projects and deadlines up on the boxes
and I write a bunch of my values up
there and all I do is every day I just
kind of stare at it
I'm a person who is I'm really good any
person's here you're really good at just
living in the moment
I know a lot of people aren't good at
that but I'm really good
at just being here in the moment I've
had to teach myself to do that I'm not
as good
of making sure I'm connected to my
vision
or to a longer term plan
I I'm like I'm like in the moment I'm a
happy-go-lucky kid
but if I lose connection to the vision
to the Future the happiness goes down
I also see the luck tends to go down
when you're disconnected from a vision
so what do I do I force myself every day
when I come into this office
um I like in a home studio here when I
walk in I stare at that
for like and I forced myself to stare at
it and think for five minutes I have a
little notepad next to me and I look at
where everything is lining up over the
next year sometimes the next two years
and I just look at it I mean if you
walked in I mean it's really not an
attractive thing I'm kind of like this
I'm just standing there kind of dumb
looking just looking at like hoping
something comes into the brain that day
walking through each month even if I saw
it yesterday
I'm still going I'm just forcing myself
to look out
you know why people tend to be motivated
January 1st
because they're looking out again and
they hadn't done it for a while
encourage you know to encourage to be
the champion to be the cheerleader to be
the person always motivating inspiring
uplifting people to never just have you
know a lot of leaders they get their pet
projects and they get excited about it
and they disappear no man you need to
encourage on a continual basis you need
to light people up you need to have it
in your heart and in your soul that
desire to want to lift people up you
know to lift them up and lift them off
their butts to get them excited about
things you know if you can't motivate
them with with your passion and your
example then what are we doing
you have to encourage people when this
gets hard
you know when you're working towards a
mission it gets hard and longer term the
more people involved the bigger the
organization the bigger the vision the
bigger the dream the longer the duration
to accomplish it the more struggle the
more challenge the more conflict the
more Discord the more disappointment the
more frustration the more doubt the more
delay all those things happen leaders
have to deal with them and the way they
have to deal with it is always being
that encouraging voice when the chips
are down when it looks most Bleak you're
still that beam of light and when it
gets dark when it gets challenging when
there's conflict and turmoil and
turbulent Seas you're solid you're
somebody that they know they can go to
because you're always going to turn a
negative into a positive you're always
going to help them see the alternative
view the next step you're going to
Champion people you're going to Champion
the mission of the cause that's
leadership part of purpose is sensing a
mission
larger than yourself
most people confuse that with a large
achievement
but what it was meant to be
back in the day in these conversations
was it meant you can see beyond yourself
I can see the suffering of others and
want to be of service to them
want to be of service to them where that
means your angry child or that means the
neighbor who's struggling or your friend
who just lost her husband
it means I can see beyond myself my
immediate selfish impulsive needs
and I can be with someone I can sit with
someone I can listen to somebody I can
empathize with somebody
too often we think of service as like
donation
you know did I donate to this cause and
by the way please donate to whatever
cause that you get behind
but there's different ways to ride
service outside just money
and the biggest part of humanity is
learning to sit with people and be with
them in their times of need to let them
know you see them
and you hear them
and you're curious about their story
and you want good for them in their
lives
not your way not imposing your values
not pushing the answer
but literally just honoring them as a
human being we have to evaluate some of
the hardest things that we do in all of
leadership to evaluate the key people
who are with us their contributions
evaluate their skills evaluate their
needs and to evaluate the ethics that
are going on in our organization in our
team are we being are we being excellent
and are we being ethical is the
questions that we're evaluating on right
are we being excellent and ethical as we
are progressing which I guess would be
the third question are we progressing if
not why are we being ethical if not why
if our people are not being excellent if
not why these are the questions that we
have to ask us this practice and
evaluation it's like every day is a
leader you know you've got to keep your
thumb on the pulse to see hey how are we
doing are we alive are we moving forward
that evaluation also brings up their
incredible challenge that we face as
Leaders which is to give honest direct
immediate constructive feedback to those
people who are trying to influence and
Lead You know to our collaborators to
our friends to our followers whatever
word that you use for them I mean it's
vital
it's vital that we are paying attention
and seeing when things are going off the
rails you know that we never check out I
mean it's a consistent process of
checking in and seeing how we're doing
and paying attention to really
evaluating the progress of our mission
when people have clarity about their
future
and clarity about their purpose it tends
to come in different categories here
okay so let me give you some of those
categories
first is yourself
I know that sounds like no doubt Brandon
but this is yourself in terms of your
identity
this is yourself in terms of who you are
becoming
and this is yourself
in terms of your self-worth
okay I'll cover those three elements
here in a second
self
in regards to your identity
who am I
self in terms of who you are becoming
who do I believe I am meant to become or
do I desire to become
and self in terms of self-worth
am I
Worthy
these questions
make you either feel connected as a
purposeful being or they make you feel
terrible
and so let's explore them your identity
I always ask this in my seminars if
you've never done this work with me is
from one of my other books called the
charge
and the charge being like the amp like
the battery pack like you know the the
subtitude was activating the 10 human
drives that make you feel alive look is
called the charge
and one of the things I started asking
people to do
and high performance work was to share
with me to generate and share with me
what are the three words
that would define
the best of Who You Are
today
like if you had to describe yourself
like let's say you went on speed dating
and you sat down uh across from someone
and the question was okay share the
three best parts of you
and with using one word describe that
now it's kind of like that right it's
like what's the three like if I had to
describe the best of who I am in three
words what would my three words be
what are your three words like what are
your three words that that is the best
of Who You Are
or if you struggle with that the three
words that would describe the best of
who you want to be I want to make sure
that you have your three words and I
want your three words on a board or I
want the three words on your mirror or I
want the three words next to your
computer and every day you look at those
three words okay today I'm going to be
this
at midday am I being this
at the end of the day was I that
we need to develop a purposeful sense of
being and remind ourselves of it you
know these last couple years
a lot of people stopped dreaming
because we were just kind of trying to
survive
we were trying to deal with and cope
with
all of the drama and the trauma and the
chaos and the uncertainty that came
along with a pandemic with global
economic shifts with lots of political
Victory all around the world we were in
this place of like just like just
watching it was intense
and so when that intensity hits us we
tend to hunker down
and now many of us work remote
we don't see his people as as often as
we used to and so we've constricted our
lives in certain ways
and that's caused us sometimes to be
disconnected from a bigger vision for
our lives
and so I'd love for you to allow
ambition you up you can have ambition in
your life and deep appreciation for the
moment
ambition doesn't mean you don't
appreciate your life now and ambition
doesn't mean you become a jerk to run
over people ambition means you have a
great desire for a great future
and that's okay to have again our social
realm is incredibly purposeful
most importantly is this and you all
know this as Strivers here in growth day
but I think this is so critical
you've got to be around purposeful
people
you got to be around purposeful people
if you feel like the people around you
aren't as purple as they should send
them to growthday.com you know it's like
maybe they need a little training a lot
of people need training
on this topic just like my friend I told
you about the woman I was coaching who
she'd never been trained to ask the
question what would make her feel
fulfilled most people never been trained
on purpose either
but getting around
striving
giving
generous kind compassionate High
performing people will completely make
you feel different about life
I think about my friendships and the
people in my life they got a lot of
purpose
and and it doesn't mean they have this
end game it means they're living
purposed lives with great intention and
appreciation and presence
so they're awesome to be around
do you have five people who are awesome
to be around in your life
like awesome
and purposeful
if not time to meet them there's a part
of Reinventing Your Life
that really says I'm worth it
I'm worth having a better future
a part of reinvention that says I'm
capable
no matter what I've been through I am
capable I am stronger than I think I
know I can build and architect the
future I desire
and there's a part of reinvention that
says it is possible
it's possible to change it's possible to
manifest your dreams it's possible to
improve every area of your life even
just small little tweaks it's possible
to have what you desire to be who you
know you can become to manifest a future
where you are happier and healthier and
wealthier and in more love with yourself
and your life it is possible I'm worthy
I'm capable it's possible you must begin
there if there's any hope for
Reinventing or changing our lives
because if you don't feel Worthy
well that's on you to change no one's
going to give you a permission card that
says finally hey babe
you're ready you're worthy you've
changed now
it is an internal reinvention of your
mindset of how you perceive yourself
and that perception of self
what that comes down to being is I'm
going to honor myself and honor the
gifts I've been given and honor this
breath and use the short time on this
planet to enjoy it and to build and
enjoy the life that I truly desire I'm
worthy of that no one has to give me a
permission card I have to open to my
brain and go you know what
dang I'm a good person
I went through a lot of in my life I've
struggled I've fought I'm here and I
still showed up today I'm worthy empathy
empathy does it look like the person the
other is listening
and is caring what the other person is
saying
and can understand it even if they don't
agree with it
can they understand it even if they
don't agree with it that's a big one for
me
can they understand it even if they
don't agree with it
ah that to me is empathy
they care that the other person is hurt
or confused or upset about something
like there's just empathy often it's
non-verbal I can see that the nonverbal
stuff is the easiest
but often what people understand is a
lot of times empathy looks like
listening
even if you don't agree it could list
like this
can be empathy
literally this can be empathy
like you're just like you think they're
crazy but you're giving them the
allowance to speak it's empathizing
enough like we all believe that empathy
is warm hugs and sunshine but a lot of
the time empathy is allowing turn taking
asking a question
waiting
nodding
not arguing
or it's
saying I heard you say this
I see it this way
it's those simple notes of validation
time openness make all the difference
every day that self-talk commands you to
be congruent with the best of who you
are and the more you are congruent the
more you are fulfilled
you can do fulfilling things but if you
are incongruent you don't feel fulfilled
think about that because your mind your
body your spirit knows if you're being
congruent if you are a person of
Integrity living the best life if the
further you are away from that the
harder it is to be fulfilled even if
you're doing fulfilling things like
serving people
so get yourself talk realigned I can't
emphasize anymore how important it is to
master this area of your life
to take control to create a consistent
routine of positive self-talk that
guides you towards being your best
every day so that you have more
opportunities you're gonna have lots of
Misses but because you're stepping at
the plate you'll have more swings you
have more opportunities to hit a home
run you have more opportunities to have
the at-bat to be your best self and the
more that you do that the more hits you
get
the more hits you get the better you
feel the more competent and capable and
so I'm encouraging you all to please
please please remember this
say amazing things to yourself have an
affirmation List have a practice do it a
certain time a certain date certain in
my world I I you know I'm blessed to run
with the greatest motivational speakers
of our time and all of them all of them
have something they say to themselves
backstage before they go out on stage
do they need to do that no
yes
if they don't see they're commanding
themselves they're willing themselves
they're encouraging themselves if you
don't like the word command or demand
they're encouraging themselves to get
into the right State of Mind to have
their best performance their best
service so that later on they can go
that was really great I appreciate that
I feel good about that I feel fulfilled
see it's hard to feel fulfilled if you
don't feel good about how you showed up
when you feel good about how you show up
again and again and again and again the
senses of meaning and fulfillment lift
up I recognize at some point my attitude
and energy in the world was my choice
and I thought if I'm going to bring if I
get to choose over the long term
and in the moment
I want to experience Joy
I want to be happy and free and loving
and light and I'm going to bring that
into each day I really believe it if you
want one thing from today if you could
take one thing as a major intention this
year
I would ask for you to choose to bring
the joy every day it doesn't mean I have
to fake it till I make it it doesn't
mean that I don't have dark dark
difficult days and moments of my life it
just means on par over the average
across the days most often you're gonna
get joy from this kid that's a choice I
was not born that way you have to
challenge yourself to go to the next
level whatever that is for you right
whatever that is for you what is that
please write it down what is the next
level of challenge for you this year
in your business if you have a business
what's the challenges you're going to
take on
right whether you call that goals
priorities initiatives okrs you know key
performance indicators whatever you call
it those are deliberate challenges you
are setting a step ladder of ever
increasing challenges not because you're
gluttoned for punishment because in your
heart
you know
there's potential
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from me check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you don't go to
school to learn you go to school to get
a degree and that degree hopefully helps
you get a job that you're looking for
but you don't go to school to learn
there's just so many more effective ways
to learn than to go to a university